here's Jake Tapper over at CNN and uh
he's
he doesn't know what to make of all of
this I mean you know he's cashing the
checks so it's kind of good for him but
it's also undermining democracy so I
guess that's not so good here we go
oh from Washington and it was an
interesting night uh Mr Trump's first
lie was told just seconds into the night
with his false familiar claim that the
2020 election was quote a rigged
election and the falsehoods kept coming
Fast and Furious about the January 6
Insurrection about the threat to vice
president Pence about Pence's ability to
overturn the election about covet about
the economy and more he called a black
law enforcement officer a thug he said
people here in Washington DC at
Chinatown don't speak English
okay again do you get it why they need
each other then they can sit there and
be outraged over what they just allowed
to happen it's do you think they didn't
know what was going to happen did they
think that Trump was going to get up
there with Kalyn Collins and it was just
going to be a Love Fest and he was just
going to tell the truth as they see it
and everything was just going to go
smoothly of course not but it's exactly
what they wanted and it's not just what
CNN wants it's what MSNBC wants too
because since Trump has left office
msnbc's ratings have absolutely
collapsed and deservedly so here's Joe
Scarborough and look at this actor he's
just an actor
so upset about Trump
see it I I can't believe I'm I'm going
to use
catastrophizing language here uh but it
was it was just it was disgraceful on
every level
it showed uh I won't I wouldn't say it's
dangerous for democracy because we
passed that a long time ago
but it showed the corrosive effects of
trumpism over eight years
and I've got to say
I I the most shocking part with an
audience
cheered on a president who tried to
overturn
American democracy
he tried to overturn American democracy
it's true couple hundred people showed
up there on January 6 no weapons no
plans no nothing
one guy they thought he had a Lego set
that looked like the capital turned out
that wasn't even true but this this fake
pompous boring man having stepped away
from this stuff for about two weeks just
watching all of these people it's like
you're all in on the grift
[Music]
thank you